[Music]
there's a lot to love about living in a
big bright city
people
culture
late night food
but there's something missing
it's there but you can't see it
the night sky
[Music]
this is the story about a small town in
colorado actually two small towns in
colorado that are devoted to space
westcliff has a population of 564
residents and silver cliff has a
population of 575.
this used to be a mining community and
then it evolved into a railroad
community and then into a ranching
community
we're always looking to do something
that will bring people into our
community and lately that seems to be we
need to invest in our sky
so they made light pollution their enemy
they darken their towns so that the
night sky could become their star
attraction have you ever seen the milky
way that goes from horizon to horizon
88 of the world's population has never
seen the milky way
it's the most magnificent thing in the
world that's what we see here
but for the towns to go dark they needed
to cover all of their lights
not just street lamps but the lights
outside every house and ranch near town
that wasn't easy this is a frontier town
and i can tell you frontier people don't
like being told what to do
we had to win their hearts and minds
it took 10 years they passed ordinances
raised money to cover the street lights
and even build an observatory
and the darker the town became the more
people saw the light
this year the valley's dark sky was
designated as one of the darkest in the
world drawing visitors from all over
okay
might need a six-pack though
well i was really hoping we'd be able to
see saturn by now yeah me too
that a community would decide to dim its
lights and help everyone to appreciate
the beauty of the night sky is an
amazing thing
you come to a place like this
and
the stars just
burst
and it's remarkable
not a lot of people are lucky enough to
see the dark sky as our ancestors saw it
and i feel that we're a very special
place to be able to look at the stars as
people did thousands of years ago
it's a humbling thing suddenly you
realize you can almost touch it
and you're now a part of the bigger
universe
and so it's just a wonderful experience
to see the dark skies that's what we're
trying to preserve
[Music]
my name's tim ducette
i'm an amateur astronomer
and i'm also legally blind
kind of an oxymoron isn't it
[Music]
it turns out
i can actually see the night sky better
than most people
probably better than you
when i was younger um it's it's easy to
become discouraged you know realizing
that you're never going to drive a car
that you'll never be an
astronaut least that's what you're told
i was born with congenital cataracts
they remove the lenses of my eyes
and widen my pupils that left me with
only about 10 of my eyesight
for the average person their pupil
automatically adjusts for the amount of
light coming in it opens and closes but
for me my
pupil is open so it's always letting in
a lot of light
[Music]
during the day
i see everything extremely bright
everything is overexposed
colors are are more vivid
but at night time the tables are turned
and it's like a curtain has been lifted
[Applause]
[Music]
when i was a teenager i went on some
additional surgery to improve my
eyesight
i got home from the hospital and i
looked up at the sky and at first i
thought i was actually having a detached
rat and i was seeing millions of spots
of light
and realized that that was the milky way
i was looking at
and it was a phenomenal
[Music]
at first i didn't really realize what
it had given me
it took 15 years later
to realize that
what i had was special
with my personal savings i built an
observatory on a hill near my house
and called it deep sky eye
[Applause]
when i'm looking through a telescope i'm
not wearing my glasses
and my eye is like a camera without a
lens
so it's focusing the light very clearly
onto my retina
i see a little bit extra light that most
people wouldn't see
you know you look at the orion nebula
and you know it looks like a fuzzy patch
but you know i kind of get a little bit
of purplish tinge to it
the sky here is like a tapestry of
interstellar dust
it looks like a velvet background you
know with diamonds all through it
it's absolutely amazing
my wife is also legally blind
she doesn't see very well at night but
most of the time when we're you know
walking or at the observatory i'll
explain to my wife what i'm seeing
she appreciates the night sky even
though she doesn't see it very well
when i look through the telescope or
look up at the night sky
it makes you realize really that all
your problems with fact that you're
legally blind or whatever it really just
doesn't matter
you realize that you're a part of this
universe
[Music]
my biggest
thing that i like to do is discover
stuff
and not necessarily things that have
already been discovered i really like to
discover things that haven't been
discovered yet if you take an asteroid
and you discover an asteroid for example
even though there's half a million of
them out there that's one you found
nobody else in the world knew about that
asteroid before you saw it
what i've been doing here lately and and
for about 15 16 years now
i've been working with near-earth
objects
my observations contribute to
making sure that we don't have something
coming up that's going to fall on our
heads
kind of first got into it probably 10 12
years old i was begging begging begging
to get a telescope and you know we were
in a very rich family so it took a while
to get it and one christmas i got
telescope then i started using it and i
got aperture fever
you want bigger telescopes all the time
so i started learning how to build them
i learned how to how to work in a
machine shop
i can build things that i wanted to
build
and a lot of that was astronomy parts
i kind of modified my life to fit this
study this kind of lifelong study
sandlot is
a
very tiny little observatory it's only
10 foot by 10 foot wide
the telescope i built
over a period of about a year and a half
and it may not look very polished
it works really well
i'm good with that
[Music]
[Music]
i don't have a degree in astronomy
i have a passion for astronomy
and i've done it for many many years and
i've i've contributed i think to the
scientific body of astronomy
[Music]
listen
this sound is the first evidence of the
big bang
and this is a story of two radio
astronomers who discovered proof of the
beginning of everything
this is the horn reflector antenna at
bell laboratories robert can you tell us
what this thing does it receives radio
waves coming from the direction it's
pointed to
and funnels them into a receiver that's
robert wilson radio astronomer in the
early 60s he and his colleague arno
penzias were tasked with measuring the
brightness of the sky using the horn
reflector antenna but no matter where
they pointed it the antenna read a much
larger signal than the pair expected our
immediate reaction was that there must
be something wrong with our system they
thought it might be interference from
the horn itself or new york city or even
some pigeons living in the horn you know
we thought about a collection of
ordinary sources that are in the very
distance that just didn't seem to be
possible so they reached out to a group
of researchers at princeton university
led by astrophysicist robert dickey who
had been scouring the sky unsuccessfully
for evidence of the big bang
arnold called and
[Music]
dickie picked up the phone and they
started hearing things like atmospheric
radiation sky brightness
all the things that they were working on
dickie put the phone down and said boys
we've been scooped
robert and arno had measured what dickie
and his team were searching for the
elusive cosmetic microwave background
radiation
he thought about a big bang source of
the universe realized that it would be
very hot and therefore full of radiation
and as the universe expanded that
radiation would simply cool
and whereas it was
extremely hot to start with by now it
would simply be
microwaves now it's so cold that it
would just be radio waves
and this nut pigeons or the noisy city
was exactly what had been causing
headaches for robert wilson and arno
penzias the two groups of researchers
from bell labs and princeton each wrote
complementary research papers with their
findings they wrote one about the theory
we wrote one about our measurement and
we published them i think unlike many
changes that occur in science
there really was a paradigm shift with
very little pushback
it was huge there was now evidence of a
new theory for the beginning of the
entire universe over a decade later
robert wilson and arno penzias were
awarded the 1978 nobel prize in physics
how'd that feel robert
felt pretty strange to win the nobel
prize i didn't feel comfortable being on
the same list with einstein but despite
robert's humility there's no doubt the
significance of the discovery it gives
us our earliest picture of the universe
from which we can extrapolate back to
very early times
[Music]
[Music]
i think it's part of who we are as a
species to ask the question of where are
we where did we come from where are we
going and are we going there alone
[Music]
the largest mirrors in the world enable
a chance for all of us to answer those
questions that mean so much to us
my name is patrick mccarthy and i'm the
principal astronomer behind the giant
magellan telescope project the largest
telescope in the world
hand-crafted start to finish here at the
university of arizona
the process of making a mirror in some
sense it's like making a cake first
thing is you get all the ingredients we
have the glass
you build the mold and we put the glass
on top
and then you put it in the oven
[Music]
it's then heated up to such a high
temperature that the glass melts until
it flows into the mold and makes the
rough shape of your cake now in our case
the icing is the hard part
the mirrors weigh about 17 tons they're
up to 8.4 meters in diameter that's a
really big piece of glass
then to turn that piece of glass into a
final optics takes another two to three
years of precision grinding and
polishing and testing
each mirror from start to finish takes
roughly seven years to produce and
there's roughly a hundred people working
on it so about 200 person years that go
into making one of these mirrors
the giant magellan telescope will be
cited in the chilean andes they have the
sharpest images in chile dry weather
clear skies and no artificial lights
it's a perfect place for astronomy
the challenge of course is how you
handle this beautiful precision piece of
glass
and so we lift it with suction cups
the mirrors are moved very carefully
because they are glass after all
[Music]
telescopes are our vehicles of discovery
there are ships in the universe and the
heart of the telescope is the mirror
it's a thing that collects the light
that's come from millions or billions of
light years away and brings us that
information that can allow us to answer
those questions
where did we come from where are we
going are we alone
you